charlemagne's imperial coronation on
christmas day 800 was a pivotal event of
his reign
and the event for which he would most be
remembered
for the first time in more than 300
years a ruler in western europe held the
imperial title
perhaps even more importantly
charlemagne's new title suggested a
possible future in which europe
consisted not of multiple and
independent kingdoms but rather of a
single and unitary empire
much like the roman empire at its height
because charlemagne staked his claim to
single unitary rule
and because charlemagne's court poets
bestowed on him the title of father of
europe
charlemagne would become a symbol of
european identity and unity
so how did this audacious idea come
about
it emerged as the consequence of
developments stretching back almost
three centuries as charlemagne's people
the franks rose to european providence
it emerged too because charlemagne's
grandfather and father had made the
carolingians the preeminent frankish
family
and lastly it emerged because
charlemagne's own life as heir apparent
and then king
positioned him to assume the imperial
title at the age of 52.
historians continued to make discoveries
about charlemagne and his life
if i had been presenting charlemagne's
story in the mid-1970s or any time
before that
i would have told you that charlemagne
was born in 742.
give or take a year
the basis for my assertion would have
been einhard who wrote that charlemagne
had been 72 years old at the time of his
death in 814
however in the
1970s scholars re-examining the
contemporary evidence for charlemagne's
birth and the activities of
charlemagne's parents
posited that charlemagne must have been
born five years later in 747.
einhardt had made charlotte several
years older than he actually was
then in the 1990s
scholars realized that identifying
charlemagne's birth year at 747
failed to take into account that our
sources authors calculated years
differently than we do
so the date of charlene's birth became
the second day of april 748.
the place of charlemagne's birth is
still uncertain but it was somewhere in
the kingdom of the franks
and he himself was a frank the english
word frank meaning honest and before
that free is derived from the name of
charlemagne's people
the franks were a germanic people one of
many that had entered the western half
of the roman empire in the 4th and 5th
centuries
like other germanic peoples the franks
had established their own independent
territories and kingdoms within the
western half of the roman empire
the person with the best claim to have
been the first king of the franks was
clovis who died in 5 11.
thanks to the name clovis french and
german history would be filled with
figures named louis and ludwig both
names derived from clovis
clovis and then his frankish subjects
converted to the catholic variant of
christianity
the frank's conversion likely
facilitated frankish rule over the
catholic
gallo roman population
the frankish kingdom gradually expanded
until by the early 8th century it
encompassed most of what had once been
roman gaul
during that expansion
multiple linguistic divides began to
emerge among the franks
those friends living in northeastern
regions along the rhine river valley and
thereabouts continued to speak frankish
a germanic language
everywhere else franks began to speak a
form of latin that evolved into old
french
the frank's own germanic language
influenced the newly emerging old french
language with the influence stronger in
the north than in the south
the influence often took the form of
loan words
modern french has perhaps 1 000 loan
words that came from frankish and pushed
out latin alternatives
these linguistic borrowings gave us some
sense of what the franks were doing and
of how others perceived the phrase
the lone words often involve war and
conflict for example the latin word for
war was bellum but the french word today
is ger which is quite different and of
frankish origin
the latin word for arrow was sagitta but
the french word is the frankish flesh
on a lighter note the franks also
brought a new word for crayfish which
gave the french nerd ecravis
it seems most likely that charlemagne's
native tongue was germanic frankish a
language in which she took a scholarly
and literary interest
at the same time though
considering the western places where he
spent much of his youth and where he
traveled it seems likely that he could
converse in old french
the frankish kingdom founded by clovis
soon became kingdoms plural
according to the frankish system of
succession when the king died that
king's lands were divided among male
heirs
these male heirs received royal titles
descended from clovis they belonged to
the dynasty that he had established the
merovingian dynasty named for a mythical
ancestor
this system of dividing the kingdom
known as partable inheritance
left the frankish territory in a state
of constant flux
kingdoms proliferated and consolidated
expanded and contracted
at the time of charlemagne's birth the
frankish kingdoms included most of what
is present-day france
belgium and the netherlands plus parts
of present-day germany
when charlemagne was born on the 2nd of
april 748 there was no reason to think
that he would ever be king of the franks
much less an emperor
charlemagne's family the carolingians
were not yet the frank's ruling dynasty
the merovingian dynasty which clovis had
founded still ruled as had been the case
for more than two centuries
but charlemagne's grandfather charles
martell
and then his father pepin had become de
facto rulers among the franks
they took over the actual operations of
the fresh government and edged the
merovingian kings into a relevance
charles martel led the franks in battle
against arab raiders in 732
winning a victory that burnished the
care legion's reputation for effective
leadership
in 751 when charlemagne was about three
years old
his father pepin deposed the last
merovingian king
and himself became sole king of the
franks rex francorum
he did so with papal approval
pope zachary approved the deposing
that pope's successor stephen ii then
anointed pepin as king in 754.
the pope anointed pepin in francia
itself specifically at sandini near
paris
it was the first ever people visit north
of the alps
the newness of care legend rule must be
kept in mind when studying charlemagne
he and his family were upstarts
many of charlemagne's contemporaries
could remember a time when his family
had not ruled
charlemagne and the franks had many
neighbors with whom to contend
to the french southwest was the iberian
peninsula
with its small christian kingdoms in the
mountainous north and al-andalus as its
arabic-speaking rulers called it
comprising the rest
all on the loose was well on its way to
becoming a predominantly muslim and
predominantly arab-speaking part of
europe
ruled by if not always controlled by the
emir of cordoba
alan de luz was also wealthier and much
more urbanized than charlemagne's own
lands
to the franxx northwest
brittany
rural
celtic speaking and hard to control
notwithstanding charlemagne's claims to
be its overlord
to the northeast
freckish rule extended beyond the rhine
river but not by much
beyond the frankish toe hold on the east
bank of the rhine were various pagan and
germanic tribes whom the care legions
called the saxons
it's not entirely clear what the saxons
would have called themselves at this
point
beyond the saxons were still more pagans
including the danes and a multitude of
slavic tribes
farther south
between the rhine and danube rivers
frankish rule included bavaria but to
the east of bavaria and what is today
hungary was the avar empire
the avars were most likely the
descendants of central asian nomads and
they had ruled this area around the
danube river since the 6th century
italy and the italian peninsula were
politically fractured
northern italy was seat of the lombard
kingdom
the lombards like the franks were a
germanic people
they had ruled northern italy for almost
200 years
central italy was people territory seat
of the recently emerged republic of
saint peter
southern italy was more or less under
the control of the byzantine empire
although local dukes such as the duke of
benevento
sometimes enjoyed something close to
independence
that is a long list of neighbors
but they all have one thing in common
aside from the people ruled republic of
saint peter charlemagne fought them all
each and every one of them
charlemagne's father pepin had groomed
charlemagne for rulership during
charlemagne's youth
when pope stephen traveled to francia
for the purpose of anointing pepin as
king in 754 pepin sent charlemagne who
was then about six years old to meet the
pope on route and to escort him for the
rest of his journey
during the anointing ceremony the pope
anointed not only pepin but also pepin's
wife and their two sons charlemagne
and carloban
when charlemagne was 13 his father took
him on his first military campaign
thereafter charlemagne commonly
participated in his father's campaigns
in the early 760s while charlemagne was
in his teens
pepin put a monastery and some unnamed
counties under charlemagne's
jurisdiction and also had charlemagne
confirm a charter these experiences
prepared charlemagne for what he would
have to do one day as a king
charlemagne's brother carlemon
was about three years younger than
charlemagne
pepin groomed karman for future
rulership in exactly the same way that
he groomed charlemagne
in keeping with frankish practice pepin
intended to divide his kingdom equally
between his two sons
each of them would be a king
and when the time came pep had followed
through on that intention
in 768 pepin sensed correctly that he
did not have long to live and he
arranged for each of his sons to marry a
frankish woman with an aristocratic
background
charlemagne's wife his first one was
himmel trude
when pepin died in 768 charlemagne and
carlimon received their kingdoms
charlemagne's consisted of a long but
skinny crescent-shaped arc of land
beginning in aquitaine in southwestern
france
stretching up along the coasts of the
atlantic ocean in the english channel
and then into the rhine river valley
karliman's kingdom was a large solid
blob contiguous with charlemagne's
kingdom
under the mayor of vengeance the
partitioning of a kingdom often touched
off wars between disgruntled heirs
in 768 of the years immediately
afterward
history looked as though it was going to
repeat itself
charlemagne and carlemont did not like
each other
their mother bertranda
tried to keep her lines of communication
open with each son
she also orchestrated some complex and
opaque diplomatic maneuvers
charlemagne's first wife had already
given birth to a male son yet bertrand
prevailed upon charlemagne to dismiss
his first wife and to marry instead a
daughter of desedarius king of the
lombards
what bertrand hoped to accomplish by
persuading charlemagne to dismiss his
first wife and to marry the daughter of
the lombard king is not clear
we don't even know the name of
charlemagne's new lombard
wife whatever the motive the move
outraged the pope
not because charlemagne was now a
bigamist which he was
but because his new wife was a lombard
back in 754 pope stephen ii had anointed
pepin as king of the franks in return
for frankish military campaigns against
the lombards
pepin had then allotted to the papacy
central italian lands that the franks
had rested from the lombards a
foundational moment in the creation of
the papal state
now
12 years later the franks of the
lombards seem to be drawn closer
together and isolating the papacy
meanwhile charlemagne and karlamon edged
closer to war with each other
at his accession as king charlemagne
faced resistance in aquitaine
carlemon refused to help charlemagne to
quell the resistance and charlemagne
seems to have retaliated by shoving
karlaman out of aquitaine entirely
then suddenly and unexpectedly carlin
died of natural causes at the age of
around 20.
immediately the succession of karlaman
became a pressing and contested issue
he had already fathered two sons by his
wife garberga
some within coloman's kingdom pledged
their support to those children
others within columbus kingdom though
pledged their support to charlemagne
garberga and her two children fled to
italy and placed themselves under the
protection of desert darius king of the
lombards
it was around this time that charlemagne
dismissed his lombard wife who was
desedarius's daughter
mother charlemagne dismissed his lombard
wife because her father was protecting
charlemagne's nephews
or whether those nephews had fled to
desendarius because charlemagne had
already dismissed that darius's daughter
is unclear
charlemagne still in his early twenties
faced the pivotal moment of his entire
career
he had a chance to become the one and
only king of the franks
but to do so he would have to overcome
those franks who supported his nephews
and he would have to fight against the
lombards and to fight against the
lombards he would need to convince the
franks to undertake a risky crossing of
the alps
mountain passes could be dangerous
charlemagne succeeded in winning
frankish support for an invasion of
italy
he and his frankish followers gathered
at geneva in the summer of 773 and
agreed to invade
charlemagne split his army in two
likely to increase speed and to make
provisioning easier these divided
marches would become one of
charlemagne's favorite maneuvers
the franks made it through the alps
safely
indeed for reasons that are unclear they
encountered no resistance to speak of on
route
the recombined armies besieged
desedarius in pavia the most important
city within the lombard kingdom the
siege lasted for nine months
during the siege of favia charlemagne
learned that his sister-in-law gerberga
and his two nephews were not themselves
at pavilla
they had taken refuge 130 miles east in
verona
charlemagne and part of his army marched
on verona where someone surrendered
garberga and his nephews to charlemagne
even though he now had his sister-in-law
and his brother's heirs in custody
charlemagne continued with the siege of
pavilla
wracked with disease pavilia's defenders
surrendered and lombard's resistance
melted away
in 774 charlemagne took the title king
of the lombards
and added it to his initial title king
of the franks
he confined the deposed lombard king
desedarius to a monastery in northern
france
together with desiderius wife and likely
the daughter who had briefly been
charlemagne's own second wife
charlemagne's lombard invasion had been
a spectacular success
not only had charlemagne made himself
the sole king of the franks and taken
possession of karliman's kingdom
he had toppled the two-century-old
lombard kingdom in the process and made
himself the ruler of northern italy
as an added benefit charlemagne used his
invasion of italy to reassert the care
religion dynasty's support for the
papacy
and to develop his own personal
relationship with the pope
charlemagne traveled to rome the first
of five visits that he would make there
during his lifetime
he met with the recently consecrated
pope hadrian the first
who would remain pope for more than two
decades
and it is surely no coincidence that
from 774 onward charlemagne began using
the title patrician of the romans to
supplement his other titles
what did it mean to be patrician of the
romans nothing very specific
but the title established another
conceptual link between charlemagne
and rome that link would continue to
develop in future decades
as for what happened to carlmon's wife
garberga and to charlemagne's nephews
frankish sources are silent on the
matter
einhard does not even mention that
carlemon's sons were surrendered into
charlemagne's custody we learned that
information only from a people source
the liber patificalis
but even the people source says not a
word
about what happened to charlemagne's
sister-in-law and nephews
how to interpret this absolute silence
given the willingness of frankish
sources to tell us about charlemagne
consigning other prisoners to
monasteries or to exile it seems quite
likely that charlemagne had these
prisoners murdered
charlene's invasion of italy and his war
against lombards in 773 and 774
was just one of many wars that
charlemagne would fight in the decades
prior to his imperial coronation
in most cases he initiated those wars
in fact as king as the french he fought
nearly every year
so rare was it for charlemagne not to
campaign that the royal frankish
announced specifically mentioned when in
a given year he did not wage war against
anyone
his victory is doubled the size of his
lanes until they encompassed one million
square kilometers which is about 386 000
square miles
these campaigns required much travel on
charlemagne's part
during the space of a single year in 785
and 786 he traveled over 2000 miles
charlemagne waged war in a variety of
locations and for a variety of reasons
against the bretons whom charlemagne
considered to be his subjects even if
the bretons disagreed
charlemagne sent isolated punitive
expeditions in 786 799
and then again in 811
against the avar empire located in what
is roughly present-day hungary
charlemagne himself led an expedition in
791
initiating the avar war of 791-796
that war ended with frankish victory and
the despoiling of the frs
einhardt himself regarded the avar war
as charlemagne's second most important
war
on account of how much loot the franks
captured
einhardt regarded charlemagne's wars
against the saxons initiated in 772 and
concluded in 804
as his greatest
the long saxon wars showcased
charlemagne's resilience and
determination
and victory led to the eastward spread
of christianity
that charlemagne attacked the saxons in
772
might seem ill-advised considering that
the fate of the frankish kingdoms was at
a critical juncture
charlemagne's brother carlimon had died
in 771
the frankish invasion of northern italy
in 773 and 774 so that charlemagne could
gain control of his brother's heirs and
kingdom was in the office
in fact though charlemagne's campaign
focused on capturing and destroying a
well-known saxon shrine the ear mean
soul which had treasures associated with
it
those treasures seem to have been
charlemagne's objective
with them he could convince the franks
to support his expedition into italy and
underwrite the expedition itself
following the conquest of the lombard
kingdom
charlemagne then continued the war
against the saxons but turned it in a
new direction
saxony had multiple pagan tribes wooden
fortifications and no towns to speak of
it was quite different from lombard
italy with its walled cities and its
ubiquitous vestiges of the roman
classical past
having initially looted a saxon shrine
charlemagne then sought to bring about
the saxon's submission as well as their
baptism
and christianization
charlemagne himself campaigned in saxony
in 775 and for the next decade the
franks slogged on against the saxons
for their part the saxons repeatedly
surrendered and accepted baptism only to
renounce their surrender when the
opportunity arose
leaders of the saxon resistance began to
emerge such as leviticus in 777
in the face of saxon recalcitrance
charlemagne's tactics grew ferocious
in 782 at a place called ferdinand
charlene executed 4 500 saxons who had
rebelled against them and then been
turned over to him by other saxons
we know about this massacre because the
royal french announce reported and
remember the royal francogenos tell us
what charlemagne wanted us to know
charlemagne's first capitulary for the
saxons issued around the time of the
massacre established a penalty of death
for saxons who refused baptism or who
ate meat during lent or who committed
anyone of a number of other offenses
charlemagne himself seems to have been
dissatisfied with the results that such
hardline tactics yielded over time
he moderated his approach somewhat
in 785
worn down by annual fractures campaigns
viticand submitted to charlemagne who
treated vitikin more leniently than one
might have expected
charlemagne himself served as godfather
at finnegan's subsequent baptism and
charlemagne let vitikin return to his
lands afterward no monastic confinement
much less execution
seven years of peace followed vitikin's
submission but the saxons rebelled in
792
taking advantage of turmoil elsewhere in
charlemagne's kingdom
again the french ground down saxon
resistance
while also seeking to redress the
grievances that fueled rebellion
a second saxon capitulary issued circus
797 refrained from imposing the death
penalty for religious infractions
helping the franks were a slavic group
the albatrites
whose victory against the saxons in 798
set the stage for the wars end six years
later
in 804
emperor charlemagne deported a large
number of saxons out of their homeland
and into franchia settling his slavic
arbitrate allies on the saxons lanes
saxon resistance which had in fact been
minimal for the last several years
finally ended
not all of charlemagne's military
adventures went so well his incursion
into spain in 778 went poorly for him
although later attempts to rewrite the
story did give the world a remarkable
poem
in 777 arab ambassadors from islamic
spain met with charlemagne
they proposed that charlemagne come to
northeastern alan de luz where the towns
of zaragoza and barcelona and their
governors would accept charlemagne as
their overlord
why would these towns and governors do
that
a little more than two decades earlier a
newly arrived outsider had taken power
across most of al-andalus
he was
and he was a member of the umayyad
dynasty which had provided the chaos of
damascus until the abbasids overthrew
them and moved the caliphate to baghdad
following the coup of 750 in damascus
ahmed al-rahman had gone westward to
alan de luz where he became a mirror of
cordoba and claimed overlordship of
islamic spain
the governors of zaragoza and barcelona
had no great liking for the outsider who
had come to rule them
so they turned to charlemagne who seemed
strong enough to offer them protection
but distant enough to leave them in a
state of de facto independence
charlemagne accepted the offer
as with the italian expedition he
divided his army into two groups
one traveled along the mediterranean
coast the other led by charlemagne
traveled into basque lands crossed the
pyrenees and made its way to the basque
town of pamplona
the two fracas armies were in rendezvous
at zaragoza
the march into spain went without
incident
but when charlemagne and his armies
reached zaragoza the town did not
welcome him as he had expected that it
would
its governor had gotten cold feet about
the whole plan
he refused to allow charlemagne or azari
into the town and he refused to
participate in the plot any longer
with little prospect for military
success
charlemagne and the franks were treated
northward
passing by pamplona
they either destroyed the town walls or
sacked the town entirely either way
their actions would not have endeared
them to the region's basque inhabitants
as the franks made their way through the
pyrenees basks ambushed charlemagne's
rear guard in a narrow pass near the
village of ross's vias
the basques pillaged charlemagne's
baggage train and killed some franks
important enough for the fracture
councillors to identify them by name
egahard
ains helm and rodland account of the
breton march
each of these individuals now had a one
in three chance of achieving literary
immortality by becoming the hero and
namesake of an epic poem that will be
written down some 300 years later
apparently though the song of egehart
just did not cut it and neither did the
song of anselm the song of roland
on the other hand became the most famous
epic poem of the middle ages
the frankish defeat in spain was
chastening it would be another 20 years
before charlemagne tried anything in
spain again
but the very next year he was back in
saxony campaigning
when charlemagne began his saxon wars in
772
he had been sold king of the franks for
barely a year
when he ended the saxon wars in 804 he
ruled over territory whose size he had
nearly doubled
and
he was an emperor
in the next lesson we will revisit
charlemagne's imperial coronation on
christmas day 800 and we will explore
how charlemagne's life
changed after he became an emperor